[Music]
we all showed up in costume together
I've only had a few fans freak out
moments but that was like huge seeing
you I was just like I'd walk around you
kind of like checking you out though
weird about my um okay I cannot believe
I'm standing next to that man just like
a bat a digging
how many costumes have you had in the
last three movies and which one was the
worst there's like a Batman fat suit and
then there's like a tactical suit then
that one was a bit tighter than warmer I
also put some glasses on cuz I had a
little bit of flesh showing I can
breathe and they're like let's close
that down you were covered that was
smooth sailing I had pajamas on the
entire time a lot of best things like
when you see branded pajamas my suits 40
pounds you have to get screwed into
yours play like 20 pounds back you got
nothing on and I'm just dancing on you
you can see the change in this pocket
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what did you do this weekend I me her
nothing very interesting
no protective gear
[Music]
no lanterns
Oh Kryptonian
[Music]
was moving for
my computer's
but missus the days were mum's biggest
concerns were exploding windup penguins
this is crazy
fighting the devil in his army you know
don't engage alone little list together
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff I've never done
battle relax Alfred I'll take it from
here uh do I know you
[Music]
there's a beacon to the world
[Music]
he didn't just save people
you need to see the best parts of the
south
as well
you don't have to recognize them
we just have to save it
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think that oh wow they just
they really just vanish huh oh that's
rude you said you've come now that's
hope you're not too late
you